thank you for your time this afternoon
so apart from looking for a life partner
looking for a job is one of the most
important decisions that you'll make in
your life so think about the amount of
time that you actually spend at work
well you know every week every month
every year and throughout the years it's
an incredibly a large portion of your
life incredibly important because it
affects your happiness and help it
affects your health and your well-being
and yet there's a lot of people out
there who haven't actually found their
dream job and when you look at some of
the research around that it's quite
extraordinary so seventy percent of the
workforce is actually not engaged at
work two in five people are daydreaming
about leaving their current job every
month that's just a a big straw Denari
so with such an important life decision
why why is it that people aren't
reaching their goal of finding their
dream job so just as a show of hands who
likes looking for a job looking for a
new job I see nobody great so basically
looking for a job is incredibly
stressful so recent research actually
found that
aside from the death of a loved one and
going through a divorce or break up
looking for a job was a third most
stressful thing to do more stressful
than moving more stressful than planning
a wedding more stressful than getting a
root canal even more stressful than
public speaking I mean like right now I
would rather be doing this and looking
for a new job that's for sure so the
whole process of recruitment is
essentially fundamentally fundamentally
broken applying for jobs is really
really messy as it's messy from both the
candidate side as well as the company
side so from the candidates I'd you know
there's obviously like job boards is
like recruitment agencies that you can
engage with but a lot of the time I
think people spend a lot of effort and
energy you know sending out their CV to
lots of different job posts also
different recruiters and sometimes it
kind of feels like you're essentially
kind of throwing your CV into a black
hole and hoping for the best from the
company side it's actually not really
that much better because you're
essentially always kind of inundated
with with a lot of different kind of CVS
from from different channels you're
getting pressure from you know top
executives about hiring better talent
and more efficiently particularly for
fast-growing companies and yet they
continue to do and use the same channels
over and over again and expect different
results and that kind of reminds me of
this so basically that's kind of how
high it came about so the founders of
hired world were all very successful
serial entrepreneurs and they got
together and they talked about what has
been the biggest challenge for each of
them in trying to ski
oh they're their companies everyone said
hiring really great talent to build
their businesses so what they decided to
do is create a company that solves the
problem for absolutely everyone and that
happened in 2012 and then they started
to ask themselves some questions so
first one so what if we looked at
traditional recruitment and
traditionally has always been
recruitment has always involved
candidates applying to companies so what
would actually happen if you took that
model and flipped it upside down so
instead of Candice applying for
companies what have you actually made
companies apply to candidates so second
thing that they are asked is so there's
an incredible lack of transparency in
the recruitment process and that leads
to an incredible amount of
inefficiencies so what if employers will
actually require to give you up front
compensation information when asking you
to interview with them and that's that's
another component of higher that we've
incorporated into the platform so
firstly companies have to apply to
candidates and when they apply to
candidates and send them an interview
requests they have to give up front a
compensation indicative compensation
information as well so it's not a thing
that they asked was so what if
candidates actually had a career
counselor / career advisor helping them
along the entire process and a lot of
times you know you you you you have
recruiters and and other people who are
very directly kind of financially
incentivized to put you into a job that
you either may or may not like so having
someone having someone who is completely
objective who's able to kind of be there
when you need them and
and and push you through the the process
of interviewing and assessing different
companies you know that of course is is
incredibly valuable for you as a
candidate and lastly what if you were
actually rewarded for getting a job I
mean it's quite an achievement you've
gone through this kind of like sometimes
a stressful exercise and you know
getting a job it's obviously like
incredibly it's an amazing feeling
you're really really excited so
shouldn't you be rewarded for that and
that's exactly what happens when you get
hired on the hired platform so if you
get hired in Singapore we actually give
you a service play one Wi-Fi speaker I
should have two at home they're amazing
so basically I just want to talk really
briefly about what a good profile looks
like when you're presenting yourself as
a software engineer to employers so in
my personal experience what I've
actually seen be really really
successful is candidate to tell a story
so you always kind of hear about like
like people in marketing and brands
being very successful about engaging
their audience and getting people
interested by telling a story a CV a
hired profile it's exactly the same
thing when you tell a story about
yourself it gets people engaged it gets
people interested so the the profiles
that really get a lot of people's
attention oh really ones that kind of
talk about you know what got you into
stuff software engineering what are you
passionate about why do you do this for
a living what what do you do in your
spare time thats thats related to what
you do at work those are
outlining those things will get you very
very far far in making yourself stand
out amongst a lot of other potential
candidates for the same role the other
thing that is incredibly important is to
really kind of flush out all the other
things that you do at outside of your
day-to-day job that could include you
know open source contribution you know
your activity on github your activity on
stack overflow and other other different
channels side projects is it something
that you should always present in terms
of you know what you're tinkering with
because it helps employers really
understand how you think and also what
you're what you're really interested in
in as well so who's hiring excuse me so
a short answer pretty much everybody so
in the context of Singapore there are so
many companies right now that are hiring
for software engineers those include
that you know obviously like the the
success stories here in Singapore you
know carousel kareena Sephora digital
but there is also a really long list of
incredible fast growing tech companies
here and there in across many many
different industries so in FinTech there
in AI there in SAS there in autonomous
cars healthcare travel there's so much
opportunities out there for software
engineers right now that it's it's it's
really up to candidates to decide what
feel that they're interested in and you
know what kind of roles and
responsibilities that they would
actually like to take on in their next
role and and also there's incredibly
large kind of public companies that are
hiring quite substantial software
engineering teams
in Singapore as well a key example you
you probably know that a lot of the big
financial services companies are
creating innovation centers and
innovation labs here in Singapore so
there's just an incredible list of of
companies who are hiring for for
engineers and it just continues to grow
and for those of you who are engineers
from outside of Singapore this and are
potentially open to relocating here
again fantastic opportunities and a lot
of the companies here in Singapore are
open to relocating candidates from
elsewhere and and the visa process here
is is very very straightforward so just
a quick overview on what we've seen at
hired so this is the average salary in
singapore by broken down by the years of
experience of software engineers with
javascript experience here in singapore
so in some markets what you'll find is
that salaries start off very high
straight out of a university or straight
out of school and then they plateau very
quickly in singapore it's a little bit
different so in singapore the salary
actually grows quite quickly as you as
you gain experience and at the very
senior levels it actually gets to quite
quite high numbers so lastly i just want
to say a quick thanks to to the sponsor
to the organizers for the jus comp this
year we are great supporters of the j s
community as well as other tech
communities at higher and we look
forward to hopefully helping many of you
folks out there at some point in the
future find your next dream job thank
you very much
you